[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
i haven't seen you in a while uh yeah we
took a couple weeks off
it was good uh i mean not a recording
because we were working hard sure it's
nice to take a little break we did a
couple pre-recordings and now we're back
absolutely yeah and thank you for uh
making this podcast your choice right
now in this moment i really appreciate
that guys it means
a ton because there's a lot of choices
out there and uh all i ask is if you
like the podcast today which i hope you
will
subscribe and uh here's our handles if
you want to follow us write a review our
handles are at inside you podcast on the
instagram and
facebook and twitter
at
insideyoupod
it's all right here you can see it
visually if you want you can watch on
youtube it's fun come and enjoy our
clips we've got tons of great clips
tons of great episodes if you if you
want to look back
and uh that's really all i have our
guest today by the way i'm i'm turning
50 shortly you got a couple months
i don't have that long
you know i'm
thinning a little bit on the top just
the hair just my hairdresser
your hair is thinning a hair but hey
it's life you know this is 50.
and uh you know i've had my hair for
quite a long time it's still good but
you know
at 50 years old you you these things
[ __ ] happens yeah
so these are the things that happen at
this point so you take care of it now
yeah you take care of it yeah you do the
work yeah uh
kate siegel is on the podcast you know
her from haunting of hill house midnight
mass she's been in
so many movies so much great stuff
uh her partner mike flanagan has
directed a lot of stuff uh they they
collaborate together they write together
they
uh she's a she's a force to be reckoned
with man i love having her and i think
she's truly truly talented and uh i'm
glad she sat down with me thank you
miss siegel
and uh hey if you want to go to the uh
inside of you store go to the inside of
you online store there's some great
merch there and some autograph stuff and
new tumblers
and then uh the patreon thank you my
patrons patrons give back ryan what do
they do
they keep the podcast going they do they
they
they donate they they they just are so
helpful go to patreon
patreon p-a-t-r-e-o-n dot com slash
inside of you join today i'll send you a
message there's different tiers it's a
lot of fun in fact at the end of the
episode i read the top tiers names out
and we do it every
uh every episode ryan has memorized most
of the names
and uh so check that out i'll be at some
conventions coming up st louis missouri
may 13th we're doing a smallville nights
in st louis
i love it tom welling and i will be
there for smallville nights and we'll
also be there saturday and sunday
signing autographs then we'll be in
liverpool in late may uh so join us and
uh yeah come say hi and uh without
further ado ryan why don't we just get
right into
kate siegel
it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
yeah what are you what are you drinking
there what is that
this is um it's called boreal botanical
this is not an ad
um it's like a little
um
it's like reishi mushroom botanical
tonic it has algebraian birch
this is why i never booked any
commercials ever in my whole life i was
like oh this thing is a thing
wait a minute wait a minute you've never
booked a commercial in your life
um i had
one of those amazing
uh commercial actor things where i had a
commercial agent first i auditioned for
commercials for 10 years
two or three times a week
and i booked one commercial one
pharmacist oh maybe two a pharmaceutical
commercial and a tied commercial where
he had stinky pants
you had stinky pants in a commercial in
a pharmaceutical commercial where i had
a rash where i had eczema or psoriasis
are you serious those are the only two
commercials i ever booked i've never
booked a commercial only voice over they
wouldn't even want to see my face on the
commercial it's
a commercial world is let me turn my
phone off my commercial world is beyond
me i know people who make a living out
of it and who
love it and it's their world i found
those auditions unbearable and i think
that probably read on my face you know
what i think it is i think that you're
just such a wonderful actor you know
that they just you know they were like
you know she's just too good for this
world
you think so but then i remember
like i always think i'm real cute even
when i'm not
and i was auditioning for a birth
control commercial or something and they
were like what's your favorite things
about babies and you know any normal
commercial actor in the world would have
been like there's smell there's softness
and because i'm an [ __ ] and i can't
help myself i said their tender meat
their tender meat
no one thought it was funny
it landed like a lead balloon
and they're like thanks so much and then
i never saw that casting office again
wow
that's amazing that world it seems so
long ago that i auditioned for
commercials and i'd go in there and i
had these fangs like my my teeth are
straight now but i used to have these
little fangs and i would never book
anything and i was like why am i not
booking anything and did you get the
veneers
i remember a manager of mine once uh his
name's dave becky and he like he he
repped me
at the time dave chappelle
mark maron like all these guys are huge
now i was like the only actor and then
all these stand-up comedians um what's
the other guy's name the guy who goes
rice is a great snack if you're in the
mood for 2000 of something what was that
guy's name mitch hepburn mitch hedberg
mitch hedberg mitch hedberg and i
remember
i remember dave comes up to me and goes
hey man um i think you need to get your
teeth fixed and i go
really what about steve buscemi he's
like yeah
but i don't think you're that much of a
character actor i think you know if you
i think if you just straighten your
teeth out get a retainer or whatever
i think it will change your your career
and he was right
i straightened my [ __ ] teeth and i
started booking like lead roles
i mean here's a hot take on this podcast
that i've never said anywhere else
same
you fixed your teeth too oh yeah these
aren't my teeth
your teeth are good they're you can get
a commercial now if you wanted now i can
i had like little tiny baby teeth dear
internet please go on earth those photos
because i did i worked for a while but
not well and not often with my tiny
teeth and gummy smile and i had the same
thing i had
a producer say to me well she said two
things she said fix your teeth and pin
your ears back get your ears pinned what
and i was like
um i had a little self-esteem not a lot
of self-esteem so i had enough
self-esteem to be like no i'm not
pinning my ears but then i got my teeth
fixed yeah but they so people you can
actually have your ears pinned i'll show
you i have normal human ears yeah they
look like very good ears but what
they'll do is they'll put like a little
stitch that way so that like front on
you have no human ears apparently ears
are a no-no in the film
were you considering it be honest were
you considering
i would have done anything i wanted to
be an actor so badly it's all i wanted
to do it was just like for so many years
the goal was just let it be a full-time
job please god
let it just be enough to pay rent and i
would have pinned my ears i would have
fixed my i didn't have like again this
is not good advice because i didn't have
boundaries or self-esteem i had a cloud
of desperation that's what i had right
and
unrelenting ambition i like how honest
you are about loving acting and like i
would do anything to be an actor and a
lot of people would go like you know
they wouldn't but you really took it
seriously you really wanted to do every
did you take
tons of classes yeah really you took
like everything you needed to do the
best headshot guy
the best acting coach i was so confused
because like i got my degree
i got in class i did everything i was
did all the right things i tried every
headshot and it was
and i want to be honest about this
because i'll make fun of literally
anything but i think people who care
about stuff that's not it's not funny to
mock that
it's not funny when somebody wants
something and they go go after it and
they fail you don't tease that
but so i
it was like 10 years it was 10 years of
like maybe it's my head shots maybe it's
my real maybe i need another class maybe
if i cut my hair maybe if i grow my hair
maybe if i fix my teeth maybe if i
and just like
just running from door to door banging
and banging and banging and banging
because
there was never really any other option
for me
wow i tried other things i tried to do
other things and i was miserable well
you know it's crazy i feel like i know
you first of all one of my good friends
is robert longstreet who
yeah i know i see you love him who
doesn't love him you were you know
midnight mass together you were in
haunted hill house
yeah he's such a great i've known him
since like the 90s and
um he just talks so highly of you and
then i'm going to interview on monday
rahul kohli is going to be best friends
see i mean isn't this funny it's a small
world
it is and i think within that small
world
there's a smaller world of people who
aren't [ __ ]
and like we can see each other across a
group and you know that because when you
like
people make fun of name droppers but
when you say to me i'm friends with
robert longstreet i know you're a good
guy
because robert longstreet isn't friends
with [ __ ] he's not and if they are
wrestles they're funny and charming and
worth it yeah rob's a lo he's a bit of a
loner does his own thing he goes his own
way
and i've always loved that about him but
he's but honestly i have to say this and
we won't get on because people are like
who's robert longstreet well look up
robert longstreet watch him in some of
these movies
he's fantastic but like the guy i really
believe rob is a genius i do believe
he's a genius
yeah yeah he baffles me some of the
things he says i'm just like
how did that come out of someone's mouth
how do you come up with that [ __ ]
it's crazy
it's crazy so how did it all start for
you because i mean look at all the stuff
you've done and i'm a huge huge horror
fan
huge i interviewed your husband mike
flanagan who i think is one of the most
gifted directors writers out there
and i just
i felt like a kid in a candy store when
i'm you know when i was talking to him
because i'm just such a you know i have
an affinity for horror movies but you've
been in like all these horror movies or
shows the haunting of hill house and and
hush which you you co-wrote with mike
and midnight mass and oculus and the
fall of the house of ushers coming out
and ouija and gerald's game and it's
like oh i'm like holy [ __ ] you are
really you won the lottery when it comes
to this for horror fans you're in all
these do you do you love being called
a screen queen or is it something you're
like i'm not a swing queen you love it
you embrace it sure why not ride the
horse in front of you
when am i gonna look down on the people
who got me where i am no and it's also
for actors
this is the top of everything because
you're not just like walking into a
hospital operating room and going 10
cc's of saline with like a
calm face for 14 years you're like holy
[ __ ] my boyfriend's on fire they're
[ __ ] vampires i'm falling in love i'm
falling out of love i'm running through
the woods i'm covered in blood like for
people who love acting
horror genre is where it's at because
like every single one of those shows you
mentioned all of those characters are
stretched to their breaking points and
then they break and if you don't want to
play on the biggest jungle gym like why
are you at the park you know it's funny
though is when i watch these i feel like
you're right too and they're the hardest
to do you i mean you could see what an
actress like you are like when you watch
your performances you just give it all
you've got and it's just so believable
and i really love that because there's
nothing worse than seeing a horror movie
with bad actors
or terrible writing or whatever but when
you see someone committing and just
invested and just in that role
it just it's awesome and i feel like i
watch you i'm like i don't look at you
and go she's a scream guy i feel like
this she she could be nominated for an
academy award that's how good i think
you are
i do i really believe you're great i
told mike i was like mike can you can
you get me an interview with her she's
like he's like well i have you know i
have
a little inside you know
i'm her husband yeah he loved you too he
was like you're gonna have so much fun
kate and this actually is perfect timing
as i was shooting yesterday
and i felt
so
insecure after the scene and i bet you
can relate to this i and this is i swear
to god i'm not joking i hid in the
closet in my trailer
after the scene because i was like
this is the one where they're all going
to find out i'm a fraud where it's just
not going to work and because acting
when you're doing these extreme
circumstances like that right where
there's no
there's no youtube video for
my boyfriend is on fire in front of me
it doesn't i can't go watch people go
through that and then recreate it it's
what we call an inactive circumstance so
basically anything you do you can make
sense of
and
in the horror genre when you get to
those moments or things where there is
no touchstone for
you must trust your director and your dp
implicitly because they're the ones who
are going yes that's real i believed it
i believe you
even as a person you can feel like a
fraud because you really are faking it
because there i can't generate in me
a feeling of being eaten alive by a
vampire
like i don't have that
so
when
it's so
it
it demands everything it takes
everything
that i have that i've built and like all
of my stability and when it's done i
feel like i just
walked into a room naked and farted like
i feel ashamed i feel embarrassed i
don't feel cute i don't feel sexy i
don't feel all the things i don't feel
like me i don't feel like them
and i'm so
like at the end of it i need to be alone
in a tiny dark space
and
that's i think why
actors need why i need the validation i
need because
i have to get out of the closet
like literally i'm not in the closet
anymore for a lot of things but
oh i want to hear about that
yeah i had to get out of the closet
literally and hearing from audience
members that you believe me and it
affects you
truly keeps me going i wish i was a
a less
intense person i wish i was cool you
know do you ever wish you were cool i
believe me i've always wished i was cool
i never i never have felt comfortable
i've talked about this a million times
but when i'm around other like
celebrities or bigger slur i feel like
what am i doing here i don't belong here
i got
i'm never comfortable i can take it i
could fake it but i'm never comfortable
i'm never comfortable even on set i'm
supposed to show this confidence and i'm
showing i'm showing it and sometimes i
am eating my own ass i am so nervous i'm
so insecure i'm like i suck i oh my god
i'm embarrassed like i feel like i'm
blushing sometimes one time a director
said to me is like oh that was so cool
that last time i could see your face
like you blushed and i'm like
that's cause i was nervous and i thought
i was really [ __ ] up and i was
embarrassed in my head
yeah yeah it was
this is what i want to tell like little
baby actors who are
trying to be cool or trying to be
successful
um
there is a you that radiates that like
your story is exactly perfect
you were in the moment terrified and it
made you blush and that was a brilliant
choice
i believe that's the secret of all
actors that's what they need when they
say get out of your way right people say
that to actors all the time in class
you're in your own way you're standing
in your own way yeah what that means is
you're trying to cover up your authentic
experience in the scene even if it
doesn't match
what you're doing on the page so if
you're doing it
a scene in the dead of winter in
antarctica and you're on set on stages
in august in atlanta and you're wearing
a heavy coat and it's like fake snow is
falling on you and you as an actor as a
person are so hot and embarrassed
i would say take off your [ __ ] coat
and be like i'm so hot and then later
the audience is going to be like that's
the most genius choice i've ever seen
yeah exactly
and it is it's about really it's about
just revealing your underpants every
[ __ ] day going for it going for it
yeah i mean look when you say you curled
up in a closet after you and this is for
the uh the fall of the house of usher
right this is what you're filming right
now
insane it's that intense it's jello
which i didn't know what that word meant
until this show what's the word what's
the word
g-a-l-l-o it's a type of filmmaking
that's like suspiria so it's like
extreme
lights and sets and people it's poe it's
like gothic crazy insanity it's chaotic
evil
and
can't hold back there's none of that
midnight mass grounded realism seven
minute monologue thing
it's just like buckets of blood and
people acting in a letter
that
i mean it just so it terrifies me like i
watch
you know mike's
films or at least
the last couple of shows that he did
like uh
the haunting of hill house and midnight
mass and i'm watching some of these
scenes
and i'm going i don't think i could do
this oh my god he's staying on this
[ __ ] actor he doesn't take how she's
oh my god he's been on her for five
minutes she's still talking what is that
what are they gonna cut away why what
are they doing okay i'm getting nervous
for the actor i'm like how the [ __ ] and
i'll tell you what
the preacher in that show
how did he how did they have enough
footage to film
his scenes because he had like 10 pages
straight of monologue i could never ever
do it
he's a genius could you have done that
what hamish did no it's not possible
hamish is a genius like touched by god
genius like i
no
because also
fun fact behind the scenes
like hamish wasn't offered that part
like he wasn't the first choice there
was a different look that they were
going for
and
hamish was i believe a fan or somehow
got a hold of the script and was like i
want to read for this
and i had been a fan of hamish's for
years like all the way back some of his
theater work he did a hamlet that i
thought was like life stopping
and
i
begged annie mccarthy the casting
director and mike can i just be his
reader i promise like i'll wear glasses
and a mustache like i just want to see
the man work
and the second he opened his mouth there
was no other choice ever
what he did
was blew every other concept of father
paul out of the water it was brilliant
from the first day did he ever mess up
his lines because i'm watching this
going
i'm not kidding listen listeners if
you're bored tough [ __ ] because this is
as an actor you're watching these
these moments
and you're saying to yourself he's
saying these lines 15 minutes straight
without someone else talking the camera
is always on him it is it's almost like
an impossibility to think you can
memorize that much material i don't know
how people do it you you do it you do it
with a lot of stuff
i mean it's just
i think it's similar to any other muscle
i think i'm not shy about it i print out
the pages and i go for a walk and i get
my body moving and i just
takes about
20 minutes of page
that's it 20 minutes a page and you have
it memorized yeah you realize that's a
gift though that's like you must have a
photographic memory or something oh it's
a skill
it's a skill i practice it all the time
if i stopped it it wouldn't work i don't
think it what i i truly don't believe
what i do is magic i believe it is
bravery
a little bit of psychosis and practice
inside you is brought to you by wandery
even the rich marilyn monroe
marilyn monroe she is far and away the
most famous actress of the 20th century
her name and image are synonymous with
the american ingenue and in an all new
season of wondering's even the rich
hosts brooke and arisha
pull back the curtain on her legendary
life and career much has been said and
written about marilyn in the 60 years
since her tragic death at 36 but what
often gets overshadowed is the absolute
force of nature she was while she was
alive marilyn was a woman ahead of her
time in so many ways from the moment she
stepped under her first movie set it
became clear that it was her acting an
intoxicating charm that brought her
film's box office success but her rising
stardom threatened movie studio execs
who wanted starlets they could control
from major studios holding her to unjust
contracts to studio execs making sexual
advances maryland privately endured all
the worst parts of hollywood sexism and
overcoming those barriers often forced
her to choose between her dreams and her
sanity
that inimitable maryland magic it wasn't
an accident she created it and became
the biggest movie star in the world
despite being underestimated and
ridiculed at every turn even the rich
has all the juicy details on her
spectacular but all too short life
i i when you walk in my house you see
a giant maryland picture that i just
love it's so engaging she was so
engaging there was something about her
that you just you were so drawn to you
couldn't take your eyes off of her and
uh
magnetism man magnetism
and her life is so interesting it was so
tragic and it's like that she's always
interesting anytime there's anything on
tv or i have to hear it or have to see
it because that's who she was it's just
you want to know more and more about
someone who lives such a short life
and she was a complex character
listen to even the rich marilyn monroe
on apple podcasts amazon music or you
can listen ad free by joining wandery
plus in the wondery app inside of you is
brought to you by neutral fault well
it's finally happening uh you know ryan
um i went to the
hair stylist
nathan and nathan said oh you have a
little spot here that's
you're thinning just in that little area
so you might want to get something
and that was yesterday oh no and today
i'm reading about neutral fall oh no
how coincidence coincidence i think not
80 million men and women in the u.s
experience thinning hair i'm not alone
right i'm not
yes it's still not openly talked about
but it should be because i talk about it
openly i don't give a crap this is
called life folks uh and it can make you
know going through what you're going
through a little more stressful and that
just adds to the problem stress adds to
the problem so millions of americans
experience thinning hair it's more than
common it's normal
neutrophil is the number one
dermatologist recommended hair growth
supplement clinically shown to improve
your hair growth thickness and visible
scalp coverage for men and women did you
know that there are multiple causes of
thinning hair neutrophil is the hair
growth supplement that goes beyond
genetics to target stress hormones
nutrition metabolism aging and lifestyle
factors that may be impacting your hair
thinning is different for men and women
neutrophil has multiple unique formulas
for men and women to provide exactly
what they need based on their biology
and age every formula is physician
formulated using natural medical grade
ingredients for reliable results without
compromises in clinical studies 72 of
men saw more scalp coverage and 86 of
women saw improved hair growth after six
months neutrophil is also trusted and
recommended by more than 3 000 top
doctors you can grow thicker healthier
hair and support our show by going to
nutrafall.com and entering the promo
code inside to save 15 off your first
month's subscription this is their best
offer anywhere and it's only available
to us customers for a limited time plus
free shipping on every order get 15 off
at nutrafall.com spelled n
u t r a f o l dot com promo code inside
these statements have not been evaluated
by the food and drug administration this
product is not intended to diagnose
treat cure or prevent any disease inside
of you is brought to you by helix sleep
we've talked about this and guys you
know with my back and all my back
surgeries and my neck surgeries and you
know ryan's getting old
[Music]
you know you just had a birthday i did
you just had a birthday you're 34 years
old ryan i don't care how old you are
but the older you get the more you
realize how important a very comfortable
mattress is
this is what you do most you spend most
of your time on your mattress
sleeping it's crazy but that's what we
do so you have to have something that's
really comfortable well helix sleep has
designed something that i think you guys
will love
helix sleep has a quiz that takes just
two minutes even i can pass it so
it's two minutes to complete matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you i mean why
would you buy a mattress made for
someone else with helix you're getting a
mattress that you know will be perfect
for the way you sleep and everybody's
unique and helix knows that so they have
several different mattress models to
choose from soft medium and firm
mattresses mattress is great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot and even a
helix mattress for plus size sleepers uh
i took the quiz and uh
medium it's like the porridge we talked
about yeah it's like right right in the
middle i don't want it to be too hard or
too soft i like it right in the freaking
middle so if you're looking for a
mattress just take this short quiz order
the mattress that you're matched to and
the mattress comes right to your door
shipped for free you don't ever need to
go to a mattress store again just go to
helix sleep.com
inside take their two minute quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life and
a 10-year warranty
you get to try it out for a hundred
nights risk free they even pick it up
for you if you don't love it but you
will
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helixsleep.com
inside that's helix sleep h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com
inside for up to 200 off and two free
pillows
why did you go into your trailer
why did you he went into the
to the closet because you really thought
that you were awful and that they're
going to figure you out that you're not
a great actress because of this one
moment now does mike as a director
does the director does he come to you
and say no seriously kate i wouldn't lie
to you i'm your husband
honestly everybody all of my friends are
on set and they're like that was amazing
you crushed it and i'm like nodding
politely because it is not appropriate
to scatter your [ __ ] around set right
it's not appropriate to waste everyone's
time like i'm so insecure please feed me
love me love me feed me
that's not professional so you kind of
thank you so much that was amazing and
mike will say are you happy or my
feminari actually is directing this
episode and he goes i'm happy are you
happy and i go if you're happy i'm happy
and i just [ __ ] shut it down until i
get in my trailer and then
like i don't know i'll call my sponsor
or i'll call
i'll text my therapist and make them
talk to me for a while because that is
the difference right
that to me
[Music]
is the way you have to do it because
that set needs to keep moving my husband
cannot stop and rebuild my confidence
between every setup like that's a
terrible way to run a show
so you it's not their business how i
feel about it and like then that night i
went out to dinner with sam slyon and
roble and i was like you guys i just i'm
gonna throw myself like you do it off
time you find who you can talk to that's
a lesson i learned in my career that
like set is just not the place for your
[ __ ] and if i'm really messed up mike
will help me that night and be like no
you were great i was there it's okay
come here i'll hold you because i'm you
know like a lonely little kitten
do you ever get in arguments because
it's like you have to stop you have to
let it go because you're the actor and
we all have insecurities and all these
things that we're talking about but are
there moments we're like kate shut the
[ __ ] up mike i can't let it go
yeah sure i mean i think it's more less
an argument and more like an
exasperation
but
i'll say this for my plan again and he's
a genius and he's like
one of the greatest creators of our
generation
he loves me for who i am
and so he's not trying to change that
you're not gonna yell at someone out of
insecure right they're not going to
change their insecurity because you
yelled at them enough
right right right and if you didn't want
and he wanted me and part of me is that
i
love the work so much it means so much
to me
i think of it as a spiritual thing like
i
love my job so much
that i always feel like i'm not
serving it enough yeah i think he
understands that like i think as
creators we understand that do you
recognize when you're good when you nail
it when you are like i am [ __ ] gold
on that take i don't need any more why
are we going again
every so often
that's a good feeling though isn't it
you just have that confidence right you
have that confidence that you just feel
like
it fills up the room it's like [ __ ] okay
this is why i'm here
yeah because all those people you can
yeah you feel the energy rise you feel
like the crew lean forward a little bit
you feel your seam partners like perk up
because they want to play too yeah
that's a good day i've had moments where
you know i'm on set where i just like i
could tell the crew's looking at me like
he's [ __ ] good and then i've had days
where i'm like man with like that i'm
thinking i'm thinking what they're
thinking and they're like
hey what's wrong with rosenbaum today he
just doesn't have it
oh yeah are we getting a meal penalty
today
yeah that's true did you always want to
do this since you were a kid yeah since
you grew up in maryland yeah
and like how do you brothers and sisters
i have an older sister
she is a lawyer for the government in
the department of education
my dad was a lawyer and an international
banker thing
and my mom was an elementary school
principal
and i had no connections like not zero
connections to this world at all
and they were all expecting me to be a
teacher or a lawyer that was the thing a
long line of teachers and lawyers and i
was like nope
how old when you when you thought
what was it about acting what was it
what did you do you had to perform in
something that gave you that little
feeling
my sister used to write plays and i
would perform in them with our friends
we always did it from a very young age
make-believe and all this stuff i didn't
know it was a career i didn't know it
was a job until i was in one of those
like gosh i must have been
first grade maybe earlier
i was in one of those like camp summer
camps where you do a lot of different
things it was just like a general
community center camp and one of the
things was a play
and it was a little tiny performance to
do for the parents at the end of it just
like singing and whatever and the
counselor the camp counselor who did
that part of it
called my mom
in the fall and said i am doing the days
of wine and roses at community college
i'm directing it at like montgomery
county community college
i need a little girl for one scene to
just run on and say
i love you daddy or whatever happens can
katie do it
and my mom was like yeah that works
that's okay
and i did that and i looked around and i
was like holy
balls
you could do this forever
and that was
that was your one line on stage
that one moment or whatever it was that
was enough to give you that feeling like
this is what i have to do
i think it was less than being on stage
and more the community around it the way
all the actors laughed and how the women
were glamorous but also like powerful
and
how
like everybody was quick and funny and
everything was exciting
and everybody loved and supported each
other and joked around and the we rode
the roller coaster together
and it didn't hurt at all that i was
like this tiny little six-year-old there
that everyone probably doted on and was
like a little actress
and
i was so
enamored by the sense of community and
belonging
that i wanted it forever
you said katie now who do you allow
people
what people do you allow to call you
katie
um so there are two types of people who
call me katie people who
knew me when i was young
and
people in my life who come to it
organically like every once in a while
like it's not like at some point
in a friendship i say and now you may
call me katie right like some of my best
friends still call me kate
but just the other day um
one of the props girls walked up to me
and said hey katie do you want to use
this phone
and i just loved it it just worked with
her and me and it was right it might
have been because she thought it was
katie parker but it also might have been
that she said it just felt right
i never really correct anyone because
most people go with kate but your
husband calls you kate
mike calls you kate you know he
no i'm thinking you know he calls me
honey he calls me cute he calls me
um a lot of things i guess he calls me
kate yeah when he uses a name he uses
kate so after this show this you did
this little play
what was next and were your parents sort
of like
uh
not allowing it but sort of entertaining
and saying this is what she likes to do
let's let her do this or
what was their attitude towards that and
what was the next thing that kind of
that you did
so in that
sense because they didn't have any
connection to this world like it would
have never occurred to them to let me be
a child actor so i did school theater
i would do any summer camp i did was
theater-based anytime i went to sleep
away camp i would want to do the play
but it was never a professional job
i went to um
this big high school outside of dc
before i transferred to private school
and
they did like a modeling agent scout
there
and when i was 15 this woman called my
mom and was like hey we want to bring
kate to new york to do some
test shoots and model and my mom was
like over my dead [ __ ] body
and i was
horrified humiliated locked myself in my
room hated her for years and now i'm
like thank you
yes
that could have just uh like it's never
good it probably isn't seldom isn't good
it's never it wouldn't have turned out
well so she kept she kept you there she
kept you there
kept me there
and then
when i went to college
they allowed me to major in theater as
long as i went to a school that had
other things so like i couldn't have
applied to juilliard or cal arts
i ended up going to syracuse because it
was a liberal arts school with a great
theater program
and
um
everyone thought that this would become
because this is a like where i grew up
it wasn't a thing where people became
actors and professional actress and
actresses so they thought it would
become i'd become a theater teacher
who does community theater or i was like
gonna be maybe i would produce theater
right they never think that your kid's
gonna become a star or not a working
actor they know no one ever thinks that
no
no they really didn't think like i loved
them but they really didn't think it
right and so um
there's a second catalyst that happened
which was
right before my senior year of college
my dad died really suddenly
he had a heart attack while he was
playing tennis dead before i hit the
ground
and
we don't i mean anybody can imagine
that's [ __ ]
it was a week after my 21st birthday
like your whole life is gone
and he we were a close family he was
a huge part of my life and then i like
said good night to him one night
thinking i'd see him forever and he was
just [ __ ] gone and there was no rhyme
or reason there was no health issues he
never knew that he had any heart
complications nothing just gone just
gone
no and he was like 56.
holy [ __ ]
it was
so unbelievably traumatic
that even to this day as i approach 40
myself i am still unpacking it and how
how my life was
um
how my life was
built around it the scar tissue of that
and so in that moment
instead of doing what i planned to do
which was moved to new york when i
graduated i finished my senior year and
i moved back to dc
and
my dad worked at the world bank that was
his job when he died
and the world bank
for some unknown reason to me offered me
an internship which is like the gold
ring of international finance
internships but i was a theater major
it doesn't make any sense
it didn't make any sense um
and i sat there for the summer and i
kind of
i just put my headshot and resume
into an envelope because i saw the
folger theater was casting
a show that needed girls in their 20s
and i started doing shakespeare in dc
and
i thought you know what this would be
great i'll be a shakespeare actor in dc
only getting money but like what how
nice
and then i got cast in play and after
the table read i was fired for being bad
for being bad oh i was bad at the table
reading they were like she can't do this
so they replaced me that was the first
time you ever were fired or let go of
something right how did that feel i was
rejected constantly i was not very good
for a long time really
yeah
i mean we all get better we all learn we
all like if you study and you do this
but do you think you had natural ability
or do you think that you just really had
to work hard to be as good as you are
um
i think i came into the game a solid b
a b yeah a b what the hell is wrong with
a b
yeah but a b is a guest star twice a
year on various shows right you're not
making a living at a b
if you want to be a series regular if
you want to be a part of the
conversation you've got to be this is
the [ __ ] olympics
you got to be an a i don't know i see a
lot of b minuses c pluses c minuses i'll
go even to d's on some tv there's a lot
of tv there's a lot of great tv there's
also a lot of bad tv and there are a lot
of grades maybe the grades are i don't
know what i'm saying is a b is pretty
good and you could be a working actor
with a b so you were you were good you
weren't bad but you had a lot to do you
had a lot more to learn
right
yes i got fired and because of this
traumatic event like my dad's this is
like a year we're still within the year
or two after he died
i thought to myself
if this world is gonna [ __ ] on me
i'm not getting [ __ ] on
in washington [ __ ] dc i'm gonna get
[ __ ] on in new york or l.a i flipped a
coin and it was l.a
just like that
and what did you do the world was like
oh you want to get [ __ ] on here's 10
years of [ __ ]
that's for sure there you go you want to
really be [ __ ] on here's how you get
[ __ ] on
i got exactly what i asked for
now this is you moved out to ellie how
long after your father passed away
um
three or four years
right and maybe less
yeah did you did your mom remarry or
oh yeah she did yeah right away
i'm nodding for those people who can't
see me yes so that's i learned to love
him i grew to love him very much but it
wasn't easy in the beginning yeah it was
six months after my dad had died there
was a new man sitting at the breakfast
evil
man did you lash out or what oh
constantly what did you do
how dramatic give me a dramatic moment
that you remember so i come home
so my dad dies in august the first time
gordon gordon peavy was his name he died
of cancer he is a fantastic person and
did not deserve this and to his credit
he was perfect he was like a horse
whisperer he waited calmly waited me out
didn't respond didn't put himself in any
awkward situations gordon was a great
man
um i was not prepared for this so my dad
died in august so by the time
i came home for spring break
my mom and gordon were dating like
significantly
and gordon was staying over it it's so
weird because my mom is married to a
gordon my stepdad is gordon do you like
the gordon i like gordon gordon's like
king of the hill gordon gordon's like
your mother has long haul covid
everything sounds like he's pissed off
about it he's like
your mother tried to call you yesterday
it's like king of the [ __ ] hill
oh my god but go ahead tell me about
your gordon and what you did i want to
hear this um my gordon was a harley
davidson driving whiskey drinking ohio
natives
but also like worked at the aclu for
union rights like just a great guy um so
anyway gordon
my mom says to me
calls me at syracuse and it's like
you're coming home for spring break
gordon will be staying over
step one
utter screaming meltdown on the phone
how dare you what do you mean he's gonna
you can't do this to me dad's just died
i give
my mom to her credit like my mom is
going to live her life the way she wants
to and she was like no this is how it's
going to be
i'm on the phone with my sister joe i'm
going to burn him to the ground i'm
going to actually murder him and my
sister who's used to her very traumatic
younger sister was like sure whatever
you need an alibi i'll help you murder
him
and i'm going to help you because i'm
going to be a lawyer so this is great
exactly
so i get home
and i get home late one night and i go
to bed and
i come downstairs
and gordon is sitting where my dad used
to sit at the breakfast table this is
the first time i meet gordon
and all i have in that memory
is like
tv static and the music from kill bill
and i know i screamed a lot like it is a
legend in my family that i was like get
out of his [ __ ] chair you
opportunistic [ __ ]
like i was not holding i was in theater
school like i was smoking and wearing
black i was very traumatic at the time
you really said get off the chair you
[ __ ] i think it's an opportunistic
opportunistic [ __ ]
yeah did he say a word
and i'm sure he was like you can't speak
to me like that gordon wasn't a pushover
but like i think the whole room knew
what was going on like nobody was like
kate's okay and she's just
kind of a bad person
but yeah and it was like that for years
i remember gordon
didn't like to eat bacon
he like wasn't a vegetarian or anything
he just didn't like bacon and my sister
and i would just mail him bacon off
it was like the parent trap but i was an
adult and i was supposed to know better
inside of you is brought to you by
better help better help online therapy i
can't tell you how many emails or texts
or messages i get
from people telling me that better help
is helping them and i really love that i
love uh
talking about something that works that
helps people that is a sponsor on the
podcast where we talk about mental
health
it's very important ryan's still with
better help i'm still a better help and
it's still
helping still helping help i like
hearing that you know people don't
always realize that physical symptoms
like headaches
teeth grinding even digestive issues can
be indicators of stress and let's not
forget about doom scrolling sleeping too
little sleeping too much under-eating
overeating stress shows up in all kinds
of ways and in a world that's telling
you to do more sleep less and grind all
the time here's your reminder to take
care of yourself to do less and maybe
try some therapy better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to ryan you like to see people i do i
think it helps i do too i like to see
the person i'm talking to but that's
just me if you don't feel like seeing a
face you don't have to you could also
text you could have you can do whatever
you want it's so much more affordable
than in-person therapy
trust me on that one uh going in
in person therapy is is so expensive
it's i i'd say some cases it's triple
quadruple the cost of better health by
far uh you could be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours give it a
try and see if online therapy can help
lower your stress i believe it really
can truly this podcast is sponsored by
better help and inside of you listeners
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com
inside that's b e t b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash
in sign give therapy a shot
better help online therapy
inside of you is brought to you by geico
geico asks how would you love a chance
to save some money on insurance of
course you would after all who doesn't
love a great deal right and when it
comes to great rates on insurance for
all the things in your life
geico can help like with insurance for
your car truck motorcycle boat and rv
even help with homeowners condo or
renter's coverage you could save even
more with a special discount when you
bundle your coverages plus add the easy
to use geico mobile app available 24
hour roadside assistance and more and
choosing to switch to geico becomes an
easy choice switch today and see all the
ways you could save with great rates and
discounts it's easy simply go to
geico.com to get a rate quote or contact
your local agent and get started seeing
how much you could save
when was the moment that gordon would
remember if he were alive that he would
say this is the moment i think i won
kate over
that you know she finally said hey he's
good to my mom and he's a nice guy and
how long did it take and what moment was
that do you recall
god you're getting me talking about all
the good stuff you're very good at your
job
well i'm just interested
and you're active oh thanks thanks um
another thing i've never really talked
about before is i was married before i
met mike
and i think the moment gordon and i
healed
was i asked gordon to officiate my first
wedding
wow and for everything that because i
thought
and still to this day thing and when i
said it to him we had a long it's one of
the most beautiful moments
in my memories with gordon i said to him
you in the way that you came into our
family
represent to me all of the things i want
to be
in a marriage which is patient and kind
and
loving even when things were hard
and holding boundaries but still
protecting the people you love and still
making room for people's big and
uncomfortable feelings i was so
when i grew up a little bit i was so
grateful and impressed by who gordon was
when i was awful
that i wanted him there officiating it
because i was like this is a role model
for who i want to be i bet he cried i
bet he cried oh we cried she cried oh
man gordon we healed and i i'm grateful
for that because i never got to
have closure with my biological father
and gordon who unfortunately has gone
and i cannot tell him this either
i was able to heal so much of that
through gordon
wow
yeah
that honestly almost brings me to tears
i'm not kidding i got like i could feel
that you know that feeling in the up
here in your chest and i was like oh my
god i can just
visualize it and i bet that meant so
much to your mom too that it finally
came together where like
my daughter accepts gordon and they're
having a moment and this is beautiful
and thank god for this right
yeah thank god for healing and second
chances and forgiveness and like all the
beautiful things
who believed in you who when you said
i'm going out to la to get [ __ ] on
who said
i really believe in you or was it just
like let her do this let her let run its
course
she'll go do this she'll be back she'll
be a lawyer she'll do something else
and this is the second everyone always
was um
let katie be katie there's always that
feel like katie's are gonna katie so you
gotta just let katie do what she's gonna
do
and that kind of support i have the
people um
the people who started believing me were
people in the profession in la like um
there's a casting director named lindsay
shag who gave me my first job
and she i remember doing an audition for
her and she had that face you always
want casting directors to have when
you're done with an audition like who
are you where did you come from aren't
you magic
and i had
like nothing and she set me up with rex
and like people like that every once in
a while i would stumble upon
these little magic friends who would
believe in me to get me through the next
like
six to eight months in the desert
between jobs what role was it or what
was it that made everyone kind of open
their eyes and go
our little katie she's got something
here i don't know she's really doing it
honestly was it a guest star on
something was it a midnight mass like
that
midnight mass was like the 30th thing
you've done i know but like even after
hill house they were like oh that's fun
she does these little horror things
and it wasn't until midnight mass that i
started hearing from my mom's friends
and my mom where they're like you're
actually a remarkable actress what about
hush
no
nothing from hush
they thought it was good but like it
wasn't like katie has a thing going it
was like how cute can you still be in
katie she'll be back soon
wow because when i watched that i was
like oh who's this
who's this she's playing a uh a deaf
writer
or do you say hearing impaired what am i
supposed to say
i could say deaf deaf community deaf is
a good thing to be okay good good i like
that but um
all right so
you do all these things
you're in la you got a casting director
who's kind of like what was her name
again
lindsay chad she kind of hooked you up
with reps and you started to get right
you got representation from there yes
and that was a big thing for you and
then you started going out on auditions
and having auditions for the first time
yes
yes and what was the first big thing you
can remember getting that was like
i'm going to make some money i'm going
to pay my bills oh i booked um i booked
an indie film called steam
called stevie
steam
how was it working with ali sheedy
amazing she was amazing you weren't
starstruck at all
um a little bit but she isn't such a
human
like you know
it takes about
what's like when you meet celebrities
how long do you think it takes like
maybe
an hour or so before they start just
being a person how long for you it just
depends i mean there's been some that i
just like you know i've worked with
stallone and i'm like hanging with him
on set and i'm laughing with him and
he's he knows me by name and we're
talking and we're like you know we're
sitting down at lunch and we're like you
know it's weeks i've worked with him i'm
still like everyone so i'm like that's
sylvester stallone
right now like mark hamill will never
not be holy crap it's mark campbell
you're working with him now
he's an usher he is and that's not a
secret
no no no no it's been announced wow
did you get your star wars uh poster
sign or did mike ask him for an
autograph yet not yet we'll get there
but like it's still like wow and he's
wonderful
talented humble kind generous everything
you want your heroes to be and a big
part she has a big part
wow mark hamill
yeah
you know
it's pretty cool it's like you know i
think my parents were the same way
in a sense that they were like
you know he's going to school he's going
to get over this acting phase it's going
to go away
he's not going to make a living at this
he's going to realize it's too hard like
everybody else
and it's going to fade away and he's
going to do something else
and i just kept plugging away because
the only person that knows you got it is
you and if you don't know it you're not
going [ __ ] anywhere
and you just always felt like you had it
didn't you
yeah
i knew that i had something like a
i had an unquenchable ambition
i was not gonna stop
i knew that then did you have some tough
times in la
the worst like what the worst times i
had
i was in a play reading class and the
plays were seven dollars and i couldn't
afford to play
i had um
doing
like the worst type of jobs like there
was a job that i did for a while where
i was um a promo girl at clubs
where like you're handing out shots to
people who grope you and touch you and
awful but i had to pay rent i wasn't
booking work i had um
long long stretches where i couldn't get
a job and people were actively telling
me i was bad at acting
i had people told you you were bad
oh i've lost a manager because i was
that
i've never had anybody say you're bad
you're a bad actor iconic kate's story
and i'm gonna drop the [ __ ] name
because [ __ ] her [ __ ] her
this one's for you
tell me
so i
was a family friend
and i got not like
like i say family like flan a family
like within the intrepid world okay i
had a meeting with
and she
agreed to represent me this was after
hush but before hill house
and we did a pilot season together
and one of the pilots i went out for was
the nancy drew pilot
and i
have never been great at solving network
tv scenes the like a bump bump joke
big bang theory things like that i can't
quite get it i poached hard on that
audition it was not i was not great
and i was nervous and things like that
and after that audition
before i think this was even
i had it was it before hush premiere
maybe
um she'd seen it but i remember if it
had gone to south by yet
she got on the phone with me
and she was like
the feedback is so bad
i don't think you're cut out for this
i took you on as a favor so i could get
closer to mike
and i don't just don't think this is
gonna work out
what
she said i did this as a favor get
closer to mike your now husband
has the audacity to even say that i can
trevor and do all these things yeah
and what was your response did you did
you break down and cry obviously i think
what i said and i'm like still like i
have such compassion for me i think what
i said was i'm so sorry
like i'm sorry i wasn't good i'm sorry i
disappointed you i'm sorry i couldn't do
better
and i was just
absolutely devastated
and even now like i feel a little
embarrassed for having said her name
well she said those things to me and i
don't think that's okay like she could
have easily just dropped me and been
like hey pilot season isn't working out
i'm going in a different direction a
million percent
yeah i i agree
let me tell you as much as i hate it
it's a necessity
that you know you we have managers and
agents and things like that but their
their job is to sort of help you and
guide you and give you the confidence
and make you better and and believe in
you and you're going to have bad days
and you're going to have bad moments and
as much as i'd like them to be just be
brutally honest you can't tell me that
every casting director likes me you
can't tell me that every audition i have
i'm great and they're just going in a
different direction i want to hear the
real truth we don't as actors will fall
apart we don't want to hear first of all
we could hear somewhat of the truth some
of the truth we could hear
hey you know what michael uh rosie you
know you just that you didn't do well in
that audition you just you
you didn't do well you weren't good were
you nervous
it didn't work like what do you think
happened there right that's right yes
but to say you're bad
yeah yeah like i've had managers be like
i feel like you're coming across it's
like a little bit too
perfect like type a like it has to be
right you have to relax a bit like
guiding somebody but to just just
kneecap me
hurt it hurts so much there's so many
stories i'm telling on this podcast i've
never told i like it i think it just it
just
it's grounding it's also like people who
don't know the business the world that
we live and we can see how cruel it can
be and we could see like your life
you're telling me about
your stepdad and you're how your your
you know your father passed away on the
tennis court just so abruptly and it's
like these are things that happen to
people and i just think it's it's just
people could relate some people out
there like holy [ __ ] like you've
you've lived a life and you've worked
really hard but you've also had your
[ __ ] downs
yeah and i think it's important too i
think
what i do
onset
as aaron as theo as
the character i'm playing now it is
intimate
and it is for you guys
it's not for me
i would love
to just stay home play with my
kids and and do shakespeare with my
friends
but i do it because i think authenticity
of life is important and i think
intimacy is important and i think people
being vulnerable is important
and
this started happening around the time
of hush is that i developed
a fan base that was girls like 16 to 25
and
i want them to know that i'm a person
who struggles who has to do things who
had depressive episodes who kept going
like this is for them
to say
if you're looking at me as some kind of
icon
you're missing like the piles of corpses
of my past selves
that i'm standing on top of
and that whoever you are today is okay
because who i was when i was screaming
you opportunistic [ __ ] at my stepdad she
was okay too
wow you're doing her best today yeah i i
think so that's all you could do i mean
no [ __ ] no absolutely i don't think so
ryan do you think so ryan's over there
ryan am i a loser
no these stories are great he's like
going whoa oh he's like in awe like this
is this is good this is this is what
people want to hear they don't hear just
boring like i'm an actor and you're an
actor let's talk about meeting
celebrities and hanging out
yeah
no this is what you'd you'd be surprised
i've had guests talk about trying to
kill themselves i've had guests talk
about you know their mom and mental
illness and crying on on the podcast all
sorts of [ __ ] like it's like uh
it's an open forum you know it's really
just like it's kind of whatever happens
but like back to you do you
you know i try to think of like people
say you know have you found yourself do
you know who you are now do you know
what your purpose is and i'm like going
i don't i don't know i really don't
[ __ ] know i wonder if i'll ever know
i wonder if i'll be 90 years old and go
who are you but do you feel like you've
gone through this stage where like
when you came out to la was there a
level of confusion with who you were and
what you wanted and like you just like
you
what were you going through like living
out here trying to make ends meet
um i think it's a pretty common story i
was going through like drinking and
drugs
and random gig jobs and hanging out with
actors and going to acting class and
like you said having no idea who i was
and um like covering up
my deep well of uncertainty with alcohol
and cigarettes
did you smoke a lot and drink a lot
oh my god the most in drugs and drinking
and smoking
what kind of drugs i mean you just you
snorted you powdered your nose
yeah let's see i've done oh god am i i
can't get arrested for things i didn't
know no people no i talked i've done
cocaine i've done
i've done everything
except for heroin good
and heroin adjacent things but i've done
like oh i haven't done acid but i've
done mushrooms i don't trust acid i
won't do it i won't do acid i don't
trust
it my brain doesn't like it yeah i'll
melt
um i've done pills i've done yeah
i've done what you've done yeah be like
like but i i somehow
the only one that's that stuck was
alcohol
stuck as then you still do it no it's
and i had to literally quit it like i
had to get sober the rest of them i kind
of could take or leave and i dabbled in
coke and then left coke and some people
dabble in coke and they can't [ __ ]
let go yeah
but for me i alcohol just pickled my
brain and i had disney i had to leave
the party was it something that you were
like wow i need a drink i need a drink
in the morning i need a drink in the
afternoon i want to have four glasses of
wine it just felt like it was consuming
you yeah it was a [ __ ] alcoholic i am
an alcoholic
wow and so you went through the 12-step
program and all that stuff well i'm in
the middle of steps right now and let me
tell you that's not fun
but um yeah i have a meeting and a
sponsor and all that talk about coming
clean and being honest with yourself and
just like that's got to be [ __ ] hard
though like to really tell the truth
like we could sit here and tell people
all day
the things that we think they want to
hear or or sugarcoat it but when you get
into these kind of positions where
you're
in a 12 step it you're just hurting
yourself if you're not honest
yes you're just [ __ ] yourself
essentially
yeah
um my favorite thing about getting sober
is that i stopped lying
and i wasn't like a big liar like i
wasn't
but like my whole life i had told tiny
lives
like oh i owned a horse when i was a kid
i [ __ ] did not own a horse when i was
a kid
things like that things that like
completely arbitrary lies for no reason
whatsoever just a [ __ ] liar
and i would constantly get caught in
though because i forget that i lied
about it so so much of my
mental
energy was like who did i lie to about
what and if i tell the story we'll just
and now i just don't do it anymore and
like it leads to some awkward moments in
the moment but i never have to keep my
story straight right
she's like that a lot i have a horse you
don't have a horse why would you lie
about having a horse well it's a weird
thing well you can see it right i want
it to be considered like special
and rich and
somehow like
like i don't know high class and things
like that i wanted to be fancy yeah i
could understand that
and so that you get like it's sort of
sad right like it's not
no one
no one looks at that lie and it's like
what a monster they're just like oh it's
a little white lie i had a horse
like it's like you know my mom you know
my family we have a we have a porsche
but we don't we don't have a porsche but
it just feels good that if i did have a
porsche as a kid you know
yeah tell your friends
yeah well you think you'd be cool but
then you get older
yeah porsches aren't cool uh do you have
trouble watching yourself
you don't mind watching a movie with you
in it or your tv show you're fine with
it
i like it you like it i never i rarely
hear that most people yeah most people
are just like yeah i just don't you know
i'm okay sometimes i'll be like okay
you're good in that okay but sometimes
i'm really hard on myself so it's tough
but you you enjoy it
yeah i'm always hard on myself so that's
not gonna change like it's not like i i
leave a scene and i feel great and then
i watch the scene and i feel terrible i
always think that i [ __ ] the bed so
when i watch it
i get two things one is a little
perspective and i can be like oh my god
look it's me i'm on tv just like i
wanted to be
oh my god look at her look at little
katie
baby teeth and big gums
and the biggest gums i got to see a
picture of this you have to get the text
you have to text me
yeah i mean i did steam the entire movie
i had all the old teeth and
a bunch of things and castle
i did the old teeth anyway
um so they have that and the second is
oh it's not as bad as i thought i did a
pretty good job
in acting and so it feels nice
it's also nice when you trust the people
you're working with you trust the
director you trust the dp trust the
other actors you're like hey
that's a nice place to be
yeah although i did um
an episode of hawaii 5.0
and you talk about those days which i
love i loved i had a great time on
hawaii five o with robocop who directed
me
really what's his name
peter peter
peter peter
peter weller yes
and he was wonderful wonderful director
and
that was one of those days you were
talking about like that whole time in
hawaii
i left set every day like [ __ ] yeah
drop the mic living my best life covered
in flood doing [ __ ] like at a bar
doing a big scene
and i watched it and i loved it like
that just start to finish was like that
because i didn't know those people from
i didn't know scott cahn i didn't know
peter weller that was an offer i didn't
have to audition for it it was right
after theo crane
and um
i kind of threw caution entirely into
the wind and i was like i don't know
maybe this will suck i don't know i was
always sucked on wi-fi
wouldn't be the first person
what's the the most favorite
your favorite thing you've ever done
what's the
you look at it you go this was the best
thing i've ever done like if i want
somebody hush see that's what i thought
i mean i don't think that's the best i
think it's like one of the best but i
mean
haunting of hill house midnight mass i
mean all these these are all great what
was for me
it was the
accumulation of
30 years of my life that i poured into
that person day by day get up in the
morning and run before set i left set
every day feeling i had left everything
i had on the field i was so
happy
the level of happy i was
maybe mirrors only the birth of my
children
in terms of like in my wedding day in
terms of just like but that was 18 days
six days a week night shoots every night
like a no money no nothing skin over
teeth
film
and
oh i have my old teeth and hush
you did
your teeth weren't bad i would have i
would have said man that girl's got some
crazy grill
but i didn't say that yeah my own teeth
i didn't notice they were bad i think
you're just too hard on yourself oh man
yeah just put that on a t-shirt for me i
should tattoo them it's like that's like
if i had a business card it would say
kate siebel too hard on herself yeah i
think we're all like that i think a lot
of people are i think i think this is
just one of the things as i get older
i'm just like stop just be good to
yourself i know
it's like
you [ __ ] up you [ __ ] up it's okay
try not to do it again you did it again
you gotta change your ways dude but
don't hate yourself for you've got some
kind of [ __ ] going on why do you repeat
these bad things that you do
you know and just because it's not going
to help you just [ __ ] on yourself
it's just going to
bring you even lower so you know and if
you need help you get help you get i go
to therapy i [ __ ] talk to someone i
keep doing these things i don't i don't
know why i keep doing that like well how
do we stop that and then you get help
from someone who knows what the [ __ ]
they're talking about and like you make
changes
but i don't know i don't know what the
[ __ ] i'm talking about all right this is
called
[ __ ] talking with kate siegel these are
my patrons
who they just give extra to the podcast
they're amazing go to patreon.com
thank you for your support they they
love you they they're just so supportive
of the podcast and this is rapid fire so
you could just answer these or you could
say i don't want to answer that here we
go little lisa what's the weirdest thing
in your bucket list
um
getting a horse to eat a live octopus
a live octopus like old boy
remember in the korean film oh boy
oh my god that's the weirdest thing in
your bucket list
that's the weirdest thing all right i
like it i dig michelle k yes
can you ask if she actually believes in
ghosts or had a supernatural encounter
um
i believe that there is
more what is it there's more on having
an earth ratio than is drummed up in
your philosophy there's room in my
belief for ghosts i
i occasionally feel like my dad is
around yeah
nice i think that's a good feeling by
the way does mike believe in ghosts i
didn't ask
he doesn't at all
yeah he doesn't believe in supernatural
[ __ ]
science science science
a sense of compassion for the universe
i i believe in the supernatural
you believe in ghosts have you seen a
ghost i i think that there's trauma
sometimes in certain places where
someone's killed or someone dies and
there's an energy there's an energy
about that um i don't know we don't need
to get into that but i mean that nothing
is either created or destroyed in the
entirety of the universe so
yeah who's to say right
emily asks was there a moment any moment
on haunting a haunting of hill house
that really freaked you out
yeah i mean episode eight in the car
reeser and i are driving victoria
pedretti she at pedretti jumps in half a
page early on that scene and that's the
take you see in the show that's a
legitimate response from me and reese we
were not expecting it i was scared as
[ __ ]
wow
yeah that was freaky as [ __ ] yeah she
did really good
yeah that show was great tall man
freaked me out he's so scary he was so
scary is tall man was he uh is that a
real person i know obviously there was
cgi but was there
he's a tall person but yeah he was on
stilts i believe or was um lifted up on
something right i never worked with tall
man so i actually don't know the answer
to that you don't know the answer i'm
assuming all right med k midnight mass
is one of the first shows to go back
into production at the height of the
pandemic what was that experience like
through hindsight it was special and
unique and
camaraderie building
at the time we were as terrified as
everybody else
and it created this um community feeling
in the show that you see on screen that
that we were isolated and we only had
each other because that was true how
depressing was the weather there was it
just constantly just [ __ ] and gray and
rain and depression
vancouver so i went to school in
syracuse which is the actual armpit of
the nation
it snows and is gray and rainy from
october until may
so anything is an improvement to
syracuse and vancouver has the most
beautiful spring and summer of anywhere
i've ever been
and so
the winters are hard i'm not gonna lie
but
i don't know production time is
different than real world time
because you're shooting nights since
you're sleeping during the day and you
need those nighttime hours and yeah it
was rainy out in the farm but like we
needed that rain for work like the
weather was a part of our lives yeah
and so it's different than this winter
where i was just sitting around where it
was harder i really got emotional in
midnight mass when robert longstreet's
uh his character's name
uh joe joe cawley's dog dies
oh my god he was so beautiful oh my god
right
i just was so proud of him i was so
proud of him i was just like oh my god
there was half of a dog and a puppet
master with his arm up that dog that is
what robert is acting with in that scene
it was
in every single actor and extra is
staring at him while he does it plus the
crew and the camera
the amount of pressure on him in that
moment because we didn't have a dog but
the dog puppet was only half a puppet he
is surrounded by effects people everyone
is staring at him and he was able to
create that performance in that moment i
thought it was exquisite oh
raj says what's your method for showing
fear or terror for a scene
good direction on set recalling a memory
when you were scared some combination
um breath work
get your breath in the right place and
the rest will do it for you so
when you're scared
you can do it before action you can do
it during the scene but for any of that
stuff
for me it always starts with the breath
have you ever almost passed out from
just breathing too heavy heavily
i know i've done that before i'm like oh
my god i'm getting lightheaded i'm gonna
pass out
oh my god
and then i hear uh they better not call
cut until i actually [ __ ] pass out
because i'm giving them goals
is that what it is you can get that like
that like spotted hive look on the skin
you get when you're hyperventilating
that's worth its weight and special
effects money yeah
where are you now are you in la i'm in
vancouver you're in vancouver oh yeah
everything's in vancouver the next this
is
everything
well what's next for you i know you got
this you've got a lot of work left to do
in this but did you know what's next for
you i have a lot of work to lot next
left to doing this um time traveler's
wife comes out uh in the spring
which is going to be a total 180 from
what you've seen me do in the past it's
so fun
what are you doing what can we expect
[Music]
and i play his mother who in the book is
kind of
sort of just a side character
she dies and it affects this little boy
his whole life but stephen moffat
took that character and made this
incredible woman out of her as steven
moffatt does
and then he entrusted that with me and
she's just this
truly
glamorous glittery 1980s famous opera
singer
wow
are you a good singer
no
can you not sing at all not even i don't
know
would you ever sing in a movie or a show
nope i'll be delved out on lipstick all
day
really you can't sing you look like
somebody that could sing i can like sing
to a lullaby to my kids right sure but
like there was that did you get a call
for the um
the remake or whatever the wicked
something there's like a new disney
musical tv show they're doing no
sleeping beauty or something and they're
like hey kate all you gotta do is put a
little song on tape and
i said to my reps i was like i'm not
gonna do this not because i don't think
i could pull off one song for an
audition but because god help me if i
book this job and i show up and it's
like josh gad
and like kristen bell and me trying to
figure out does that terrify you does
that just terrify you
yeah i i just got the like hot feeling
who do you want to work with if you
could work with one director right now
out there obviously other than mike
who would it be
like let's talk big directors
i'm trying to narrate actually what i'm
honestly trying to do is think of
someone who's not a white male
um but i don't really have that so
stephen soderbergh
because it's always weird
it's always sort of out there
and um like he'll shoot an entire movie
on his iphone or he makes a movie about
a call girl in a time where nobody was
allowing sex work to be anything other
than a fault
um
i really love him
i love the coen brothers they're also
doing crazy stuff i would love to dip my
toe in comedy in that way that
particular brand of dark comedy
yeah um shonda rhimes is on my bucket
list i think she
like mike is a genre creator like when
you know you know exactly what a shonda
rhimes show is in terms of like glamour
and sparkle and like
wit
ah you know someone asked me if i would
do nudity
and i think i would if it was the right
i i think i would if it was just the
right director of the right piece
if it just seemed like you know this is
part of it it's not like jackass or i'm
like nailing my balls to the [ __ ]
floor you know what i mean but uh
yeah
but i think i would do would you would
you do nudity
the only time i avoid is um did you ever
see
you know before sunrise then they had
that after sunset
and julie delphi does that whole
argument topless
yes
something like that because to me it was
completely necessary because that was
completely truthful in the moment
because when you're in that relationship
you're not putting a shirt on to fight
with someone yeah
and so something like that i don't i
never do i won't do
i'll let them simulate it with a double
but i don't do sex i don't do kissing i
don't do i don't do it
you don't do kissing
wait wait wait
what
i won't do it you wait you won't do
kissing
well yeah i'll do i did kissing the last
time i did kissing was in hill house
and otherwise i'll fake it like you can
fake it with camera angles or they can
kiss your neck or they can do that but i
don't like to do
mouth-to-mouth kissing
really
that i mean that's something that i did
i learned today
because
if you're going to simulate sex it has
to be someone else
wow have you ever been offered something
and you turn it down because of that no
generally people work around it because
you can't that's the whole point you can
work around it
if the and listen
if the kiss is extremely important and
i'm like this is great
we need this moment for whatever it is
but if it is the two people are about to
have sex i'm like he can kiss my neck
he can grab me and we can be face to
face
i don't need to french somebody to start
a sex scene
i don't and i don't
for me it's a hard boundary
wow i i appreciate that you stick to
your guns
i try yeah
wow
yeah i've had to kiss um you like it
i have
sometimes i have not liked it like i
wish that we didn't have to kiss and
then there's been some times where i'm
like well this didn't suck you know the
person's breath was nice
it was sensual
we're both respect each other uh
didn't suck
but there's other times
but there's other times where i'm like
oh man
i did not look forward to this but this
is this is part of the job
i love this conversation i love talking
to you i had such a good time having me
yeah yeah i want to hang out with you
guys sometime we have to all hang out
totally welcome hang out with us come up
to vancouver or when we come back to l.a
we would love
i would love it invite uh rob and myself
we'll uh we'll come over and and just
wait until you talk to rahul it's gonna
be
like rahul is one of the funnest
interviews i've ever seen really i could
talk to him about anything
anything
nothing is off limits he is insightful
and vulnerable and honest and funny
you're gonna have a great time i can't
wait this has been a real treat thank
you for doing this
thanks for having me yes you're awesome
keep up the great work i look forward to
seeing everything you freaking do
yay
no kissing all right no kissing maybe on
the neck on the neck on the neck on the
neck
all right i'll see you later bye
yeah she was uh she was fun i you know
it's it's
it's nice to see when another actor
talks about their nerves and how
you know when they're first on set and
they're you know they want to be great
it's you want to be great it's that
yearning for to be you know just
impressed to
to be we all have it
and i think she she just has that she
wants to be good she wants to come
through she wants to do her job and she
talks about those insecurities and uh
i've felt those insecurities
insecurities before
it's always nice ryan when you when you
learn from your guests or you can uh
what's the word when you could uh relate
relate relate is the word guys thanks
for listening to the podcast today
please subscribe if you like this
interview please uh subscribe write a
review it helps the podcast
substantially there's so many podcasts
that's all i ask of you that's it uh
check out the uh inside of you online
store for awesome merch also the sunspin
my band we have a website sunspin.com
you can book uh zooms with me you can
buy cool merch um there's that i'll be
in the st louis at the uh fan x st louis
fan expo that's uh may 13th 14th and
15th may 13th we're doing a smallville
nights that's an improv show with me and
welling and then i'll be in liverpool
later that month
and uh thanks my patrons my lovable
patrons for my lovable
patrons for joining patreon and uh
giving back to the podcast you really
keep the podcast afloat and i couldn't
do without you i want to say thank you
ryan i love having him here
he's my main man thick and thin bryce
thanks for uh working so hard on this
podcast jason my editor you're rocking
it um and everybody at westwood won
cumulus uh thanks for all the the love
and the support and all my friends and i
just want to say continue on rock on uh
i appreciate you and right now why don't
we just read the top tiers let's do it
these are the top tier patrons here we
go can we have some music jason
that might add something to it
just like some recent sports center
music highlights yeah jason's either
added music right now underneath slowly
or nothing
so jason we'll see what you do we'll
find out maybe i'll just cut out what
i'm saying right now
here we go nancy d leah s
i did the old lick
nancy d leah s sarah v little lisa
yukiko jill e brian h nico p robert b
jason w kristen
allison l raj c joshua d c j p jennifer
n stacy l gen s jamal f janelle b
kimberly e mike e l don sopremo 99 more
ramirez santiago m chad w leanne p
jeannine r maya p matty s belinda n
chris h dave
uh
e
h h spider-man chase sheila g brad d
ray h tabitha t tom n liliana a talia m
betsy
uh
god
betsy d that's correct my friend chad l
richelle marion uh meg k trav l dan and
big stevie w angel m rhiannon c cory k
super sam deb nixon michelle a jeremy c
andy t cody r gavinator david c john b
brandy d yvore camille s the c joey m
willie f we're getting into the nitty
gritty here
david h
i think that's david hall
oh hey dave hall how are you doing
brother
uh adelaide and omar i what if i just
did that voice lena and design otg
eugene and leah chris p nikki g cory
nicole patricia heather l
jake b james b bobbitt
able f joshua b tony g
megan t mel s orlando c john b caroline
r rob e paul c christine s sarah s eric
h spring spring is here
and jennifer
are
i really couldn't do this show that
actually top to your patrons and all
patrons thank you thank you for all the
support and i'm fine i think i i posted
on something on patreon that you know i
sent a message that you know i was a
little under and
i came back from mexico which i had a
great time but uh i think i was
dehydrated because for one day i had no
energy and i felt maybe a tad nauseous
and i was a little achy and so i got a
pcr coven immediately i'm negative and
then it was gone 24 hours is it amazing
that a lot of the things
that als can be cured
with hydration
that's so true isn't it
frustrating i'm gonna drink some water
right now
that's why um
oh this is nice we're just getting some
uh asmr
yeah what's that stand for
it stands for doing things into the
microphone like this
i don't know what it stands for
i just know what it is guys thank you
for choosing this podcast once again
thanks for uh all the support and all
the love um
join me next week we have another great
guest and uh
yeah all i have to say is thank you from
uh myself michael rosenbaum for myself
ryan diaz hey in the hollywood hill in
california
you're right
yeah i don't know i'm just indigestion
guys be good to yourself most
importantly have a great week and uh
seriously thanks for listening hopefully
you'll join us next week and i'll talk
to you soon
[Music]